But the time was right.
You know,
and then I started having issues with my good eye as well after the gas fight.
So I'm like,
you know,
this is a word now because you,
you had oil in one of your eyes.
Yeah.
Can you explain how that was going on?
So when I detach my retina,
um,
they did what's called a slur or buccal.
Uh,
if you,
if you've watched their surgery,
it's absolutely disgusting.
But,
uh,
one of the things that they do,
the gas inside your eye,
and I think if I'm getting this wrong,
I apologize to all doctors,
but the kind of kind of helps hold the retina in place.
Um,
but you can't fly with that.
And I was filming a movie in England a few weeks later.
I said,
and I said,
you can't do this,
and I'm filming a move.
And they went,
okay,
there's another way we can do it.
It's a little more unconventional.
We can put oil inside there,
but then with that you can fly.
So I'm like,
okay,
cool,
do that.
So,
uh,
they did that,
yeah.
You know,
it's
Nah.
And then it really detached.
And then I got glaucoma.
I just had a lot of bad luck.
I did whatever can go wrong with an I trust me.
I went through it.
But it looks different now.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
But it looks better than it looked great.
What did you do?
It looks great.
Don't worry about a job.
Oh,
you don't want to talk?
No,
no,
you're good.
You got it.
It's okay.
It's a,
it's a corrective lens.
Oh,
okay.
It's a corrective lenses.
A prosthetic.
So can you see well,
out of that,
I see.
'EM At tiny,
tiny,
tiny bit.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So I don't,
I don't really see out of it.
And divisions very blurred.
I'm going to,
I was able to pass the test to pass,
to be able to clear by commission to fight.
You've got to have 2100 vision,
which I was able to scrape by with the skin of my teeth.
Wow.
You know,
so I'm a doctor was always amazed that I could still see to that amount if I,
if I squinted in the right direction and a turned here and the light was just
right,
I could just about make out 2100.
Wow.
So,
uh,
but what happens is then that then,
cause you see in two different images distorted him and you see your brain
councils the distorted one,
you know,
so with the depth perception remains the same.
No depth perception is a real issue.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
it was an issue throughout my last few fights.
For me,
the main thing,
I mean,
as I say,
you know,
uh,
I was cleared medically by the doctors and you know,
the UFC were very,
very on top of all of that.
The UFC,
you know,
send me to a number of different doctors and whatnot.
And as I say,
uh,
pass the test just,
but it was,
and every time I did the doctors were like,
we don't recommend that you fight,
you know,
you,
of course,
2100 vision,
it's still clinically blind.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
um,
but,
but yeah,
yeah,
there you go.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
But it never slowed me down.
It didn't slow it down.
That's what's crazy
looking by now.
If I sit there at night and get drunk,
watch my old fights.
I've never done that once.
But if I have a Douchey,
some old fights,
by which occasion just happens by chance,
you know,
afterwards I'm always calling for a shot at the belt or whatever.
As it's more laughs,
fuck with this guy thinking,
get out of it.
He's out of his mind,
you know,
absolutely out of his mind.
But at that time,
it quitting and trying to not be come the champion did not even occur to me for
a split second.
Giving up never even occurred to me for a heartbeat.
Why is that?
Is this how you've always been?
This is something I still felt.
I still felt that I could,
I could win it.
Simple as that,
you know?
Um,
but a lot of guys have the lost most of the use of one of their eyes would have
been done.
Yeah.
For sure.
No,
no chance.
It's not worth it.
Yeah,
no,
I know.
Um,
and
probably the smart thing to do would it were,
would have been one of those guys.
But for me,
you know,
I,
it meant a lot to me out.
I want to,
I wanted to become the champion.
I knew I could become the champion,
contrary to popular belief.
And,
um,
this is me.
They,
they,
it was my identity.
And until I won that belt,
I wasn't happy.
Now when I want it,
my wife said she wanted me to be.
So when I fought Luke in,
in La,
she said,
if you win,
I want you to retire.
I said,
bed.
If I lose,
then I'll retire.
Okay.
Cause Fair enough.
I got my towel sharp.
You know,
it didn't go on my way.
It is what it is.
I would have had closure on that.
I said,
well,
if I win,
yeah.
The fucking mind.
If you think I'm going to retire this,
come on.
Oh,
the jump we did the world,
they're going to milk it for a little bit.
Finally earn some decent pay days,
you know?
Uh,
so yeah,
but,
um,
it all worked out.